hello welcome hi
I owe you an apology
how rude of me to have touched your
belongings without asking
oh no it's cool I was just confused well
I can assure you there was no funny
business
allow me to explain
I lifted your cellular phone to wipe
down the dresser
and it accidentally came undone yeah
rather than meddle with it further
I left it that way
how foolish with me
it's fine
I wasn't trying to snitch
snitch
rat you out
tattletale
yeah
oh don't you worry about that
I can assure you
I don't answer to anyone
right
all I know is sometimes but
if there's too many white people I get
nervous you know
[Laughter]
oh oh no
no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no I do something
that's not my experience not at all
the Armitage is I so good to us
they treat us like family
[Music]
Rose his dog got really sick so he has
to be at the vet first thing in the
morning oh yeah oh how terrible
roast Keys lucky
Rose
[Music]
what is your purpose Chris
what
in life what is your purpose
right now is
is finding those keys yeah
fire
it's a reflection of our own mortality
we're born we breathe and we die Rose
I'm lucky
even the sun will die someday
but we are divine
we are the gods trapped in cocoons Rose
oh
be careful bro what the
I didn't do anything what the is
going on
where are those keys Rose
you know I can't give you the case right
babe
foreign
[Music]
yes I did Jeremy grab his legs please
take him downstairs Dean help him I can
get him alone no you can't you've
already damaged him enough
foreign
[Music]
yeah that Christmas
you don't have any have anything here
this is our summer home just got in
today so once
oh
there was a girl
and the girl
the two
connected
either
when the girl ate
her food was given to her whoa
but when the shed was hungry
she had to eat rabbit
and bloody
the girl
received wonderful toys so
and cushy
with the shadows of stories it was so
sharp and gold
its eyes through her fingers when she
tried to play with
play with the girl
better hands and Prince
and fell in love with the shadow
at that same time
and Abraham
it didn't matter if she loved him or not
he was a Tethered to the girl's Prince
after all
then
the girl
first child
a beautiful baby girl
The Shadow
shake it back to a little monster
hungry was born laughing
the girl had a second child a boy this
time they had to cut her open and take
him from her belly the shadow had to do
it all
I'm self
she named him Pluto he was born to love
fire
so you see
the shadow hated the girl
so
one day
realize
she was being tested
my God
[Music]
excuse me
what do you want
you could have my wallet you could have
the car game
you could have the boat for a like here
nobody wants the boat dad
come on
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
everything
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
nope nope
[Music]
okay okay
oh
oh God
don't miss Jupiter's claim
the poor kids
cloverell man
are you trying to prank Haywood it's on
you stole that horse
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]
oh
my God
you guys see that
[Music]
uh stay in your seats
this is new uh they're early
they're giving us a real show today that
they are they're giving us a real show
today
they're ready we're ready
welcome to the DAR lasso experience only
at Jupiter's claims please remember to
avoid using your cell phones or any
flash photography during the event
bear with us now trained animals can be
unpredictable
now sit back stay in your seats and
enjoy the star lasso experience
foreign
[Music]
thank you
laughs
[Music]